Way back in lesson one, we reviewed
some of the problems of U.S. healthcare.
Too many errors is another problem.
In it's landmark 1999 publication,
To Error is Human,
Building a Safer Health System, the
institute of medicine famously said that
from 44,000 to 98,000 Americans,
are killed each year in U.S.
hospitals due to entirely
preventable reasons.
Many of those listed,
such as adverse drug events,
improper transfusions,
wrong side surgery, and
mistaken patient identities,
have to do with mishandling of data.
This leads to one of
the key arguments for
adoption of electronic medical records.
However, electronic records themselves,
can be a new source of error.
We now turn to that.
First we need to acknowledge
the magnitude of the challenge.